welcome to illyria and welcome back the
things fans
if you haven't guessed yet in this video
we're talking all things she's the man
also known as the 2006 film that gave us
plenty of laughs plot twists and more
importantly a love story between amanda
bynes and channing tatum
we'll be delving into everything from
hilarious behind the scenes moments to
shocking facts about the comedy you
would never guess were true
hop in losers we're heading to boarding
school don't forget your disguises
alright so everybody understand channing
tatum may not have been the a-list actor
he is in hollywood today but that
doesn't mean he didn't come into she's
the man with everything he had
in fact one of the best and most
memorable scenes in the film was
improvised by him remember when
sebastian gets really jealous of dukes
flirting with olivia in the gym
well let's just say the way he
dramatically flipped his flip phone open
wasn't scripted um yeah what
um can i call you back because
speaking of channing tatum as duke his
role in the film definitely put him on
the map in the entertainment world and
we're here to tell you that if it
weren't for amanda bynes
channing may have never broken
hollywood's top tier the filmmakers were
apparently skeptical about hiring him
because of the age difference he had
with amanda your acting slash
model skills show them anger
but amanda begged producers to cast
channing in the role she told them this
guy's a star and that every girl will
love him
she wasn't wrong i'm gonna act like a
girl and you're gonna talk to me okay
ew do i have to she's the man is far
from being an action movie but you have
to admit it did have its fast-paced
moments
there were definitely plenty of fights
that could get a bit dangerous
but that didn't stop the actors from
actually performing a lot of their own
stunts remember that iconic fight scene
that happened in the bathroom
well the actresses were actually
throwing one another around in that
scene
no scent devils in sight alex and laura
and i were so excited to actually
physically fight each other if you
hadn't already put two and two together
having comedy queen amanda bynes and
channing tatum on one set was nothing
but hilarious
in fact taking just one look at their
behind the scenes moments and bloopers
will have you wondering how exactly they
managed to compose themselves to get all
the filming done
take a look do you have your number 1
800
one more time we're taking you back to
high school english class with this next
tidbit
have you ever heard of shakespeare's
play twelfth night the one that follows
viola who after being shipwrecked with
her brother sebastian
decided to disguise herself as a man in
order to get a job
well she's the man is actually based on
that play
besides the obvious similarities in the
character's names the two schools in the
movie
illyria and cornwall are both locations
in the play duke's last name
orsino is also a character in the play
who ironically plays a duke
and the restaurant cesario that's
featured in the film is named after
shakespeare's character cesario
mind if we join no no no no no uh
she's the man might not feature
shipwrecks in sword fights but it does
feature a lot of soccer
in fact a lot of the movie characters
are supposed to be soccer pros
including amanda bynes character viola
well we all know amanda is more into the
arts so getting her field ready took
some time
even if it was just for the cameras she
had to go through weeks of intense
soccer training so she could look
believable for the film
the actor's life isn't just learning
lines guys you know i trained for it
i definitely you know i got much
stronger in my legs and i was able to
kick the ball hard
like every other movie not everything
shot on set makes its way into the
film's final cut no matter how much we
think it would make the movie better
that's why they give us deleted scenes
and we bet this one from she's the man
will make you feel just as satisfied as
we did
viola did actually get her revenge on
her ex-boyfriend justin
we just never got to see it the scene
shows viola kicking a soccer ball at a
dunk tank target and gets to watch
justin fall into the tank of water
fine end of relationship it's safe to
say that amanda bynes definitely went
all in when it came to showing up and
playing the best viola and sebastian she
could
just wait until you hear this next fact
in order to really prepare for her role
and learn how to mimic men she would
actually go out to the mall and observe
them so she could build her own
character
that's dedication you're the man yes i
am not only did amanda put in the extra
time to head to public locations and
study for her role but she also went
through a lot when it came to actually
transforming from viola to sebastian
aside from the makeup and let's face it
atrocious sideburns
she also had to wear four layers of
clothing underneath her camera ready
ones
we also can't forget about the muscle
suit on top of it all to make sure she
bulked up
hey you forgot this
julio where'd you money amanda bynes
might have pulled off the role of
playing a boy perfectly but she wasn't
exactly happy with the end result
in fact she's even said she wasn't able
to watch herself in the movie because
she hated the way she looked
however she did admit that her role in
this film was a cathartic experience
because it wasn't easy for her
gonna be a time when you're gonna have
to come out of the closet and just
accept yourself for who you are
a channing tatum wasn't the only one who
was close to not landing the role in the
film
james kirk was cast as viola's real twin
sebastian but originally producers had
someone else in mind
the one the only jessie mccartney well
him and his beautiful soul of course
jessie was their ideal actor because of
how similar his features were to
amanda's
and because he was a pretty big deal in
2006.
for the most part she's the man is
pretty appropriate for most ages
it's a solid pg-13 but it wasn't always
that way
in fact it was the exact opposite just
because you wear a wig
doesn't prove you're a girl the comedy
was originally meant to be sexy and edgy
but the scriptwriters eventually had to
tone it down
the strict rules even prohibited them
from saying balls or kumquat as an
alternative
is it just me or does this soccer game
have more nudity than most
coach dinklage could give any comedian
and she's the man a run for their money
he added a whole other layer to the
comedic segments in the film
okay tough guys you're in a box get out
of my stadium
and that's actually because the role was
written with a pretty famous comedian in
mind
peter dinklage way before even game of
thrones
writer karen mccullough was a huge fan
of dinklage they weren't able to book
him but vinnie jones still did an
epic job look in the manual
what manual speaking of vinnie jones you
would think by how well he pulled off
coach dinklage that he'd spent years
studying the craft of acting but that's
not exactly true
jones is actually a former professional
soccer player he played for major uk
teams like chelsea wimbledon and leeds
united
it was all or nothing for amanda vines
as we discussed earlier
she took time to study how boys acted
spent hours transforming her face and
body to look like sebastian and now
we're telling you she even had a reason
for sebastian's slight accent
yeah i'm doing great you know i'm just
busy being a guy while spending a lot of
time preparing with director andy
flickman
she decided to incorporate his southern
accent into her character
have you ever watched choose the man and
thought wow this movie seems so familiar
it's probably because you've watched the
disney film motocross the early 2000s
film was also based on the 12th night
the similarities don't end there in the
movie a young girl disguises herself as
her brother so she can compete in a
motocross competition
yep almost the exact same plot after
everything this young woman did
the way she masqueraded as her brother
kept our identity a secret
this scene in the film came super close
to being classified as a blooper
but the editors thought that channing
tatum's mistake worked perfectly with
the vibe
while walking in the change room
channing was meant to hit malcolm's
actor james snyder with a towel but he
accidentally hit him in the eye
it wasn't scripted but it definitely
added more humor to the scene
no harm no foul right james yeah okay
homie honestly we've come to the
conclusion that channing tatum is just
funny without even trying to be
and the proof is in his audition for the
role of duke during the audition he
supposedly stuck
a tampon up his nose but he forgot to
take out the applicator
so really he ended up just sticking
plastic in his nose
you're right by the way these things
actually work while yes she's the man is
arguably one of the best comedies from
the mid-2000s it isn't just any comedy
the message behind the film and its
script go beyond any innocent pg-13
movie it was meant to be a huge
breakdown on how society views gender
norms
although viola was a girl she was just
as good as the boys at soccer but did
not have the same opportunities because
of her gender
not enough girls signed up what so they
just cut us they can't do that
if you've been looking for another movie
like she's the man that'll make you
laugh until you cry
you can check out films like legally
blonde and 10 things i hate about you
they all have the same screenwriter so
you can be assured that the humor will
be right up your alley
getting to really delve into the behind
the scenes moments of a film makes these
blockbuster hits even more intriguing
who knew that these facts could take a
simple comedy like she's the man to a
whole other level did you learn anything
new about this 2006 hit
let us know what your favorite bts was
in the comments section below
we can't wait to read what you think
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up
talk to you soon
[Music]